[Music]
a third of the global workforce works
remote yet two-thirds of them are
disengaged in their job I work remote
for over eight years
and while I get the freedom and
flexibility to work when where and how I
want there's a dark side to working
remote that does not get talked about in
our culture which is isolation which
leads to loneliness and unhappiness
because you're not getting the same
human contact you would be if you're in
a physical office space and so if you
work remote you're much less likely to
want a long-term career your company is
what we found and that's because you're
not having the human interactions that
are required to build strong
relationships which lead to not only
better business results but more
longevity within a company even if you
work in a physical office you could feel
like a remote worker to so many of us
eat lunch at our guests in isolation and
new research found that if you're in an
open office space you're actually less
social the promise of technology was to
connect us all in a meaningful way yet
what has really happened is it's become
more isolating because we're using the
technology instead of having
face-to-face conversations instead of
meeting with someone in the office
face-to-face or picking up the phone we
look down at our screens we tap our
phones 2600 times a day we look at our
phones every 12 minutes and even in
meetings we're sending five texts up to
half of a workers day is spent using
technology over face-to-face the biggest
culprit is email we're constantly
sending and receiving emails and that's
led to a lot of misunderstanding and one
face-to-face interaction is more
successful than 34 emails exchanged back
and forth so instead of hoping that
someone understands you all you have to
do is walk a few steps or pick up the
phone and explain what you mean and by
creating a deeper understanding you
build on that relationship and you
become more effective in doing your
projects we need more self-awareness for
how we're using technology because we're
tapping our devices over 2,600 times a
day looking at our phone every 12
minutes we are so addicted but
might not be realizing it because it's
normal behavior and it's been normalized
in culture for people to look at their
phones wherever they are in a boardroom
on the subway walking down the street
and so we need to account for this
behavior because the more we're using
technology the less were having FaceTime
and phone calls which lead to fewer
relationships weaker relationships so
it's important to always account for our
basic unity to connect with other people
in a human way and not let technology
trick us into thinking we have a lot of
friends and that we're super connected
and then we're hyper focused so we need
a delicate balance of alone time and
time with other people in order to be
fully productive and happy and fulfilled
in our job
[Music]